Diane is in Boston Mass hi Diane how are
you I'm great
James is very good it happened to me how
can I help
any day after I turned 18 I was in a
severe car accident and lost in to about
half a million dollars in medical debt
and it just kind of lingered over me I
know 31 I'm on disability I'm a single
mother I'm sure you can hear in the
background and I just I understand the
whole snowball effect I'm still sitting
on this just half a million dollars a
medical bag mm-hmm then what is your
income I'm on disability I'm sixteen
years $16,000 a year yeah all right
and what is the nature of your
disability um I shattered my skull I've
had five open brain surgery for the six
of my brain removed
goodness gracious kiddo well thank God
good that was all from the car wreck yes
and you had no life and I mean you had
no health insurance I was in high school
so everything that was covered with
covered by the auto insurance my parents
had mm-hmm but there was no health
insurance to cover you I have no idea of
something my parents refused to talk
about some of these brain surgeries have
been covered by health insurance from
disability and I'm a go-getter so I had
a job for a long time and I take it
there was not another party that was at
fault right no I hit black ice at 20
miles an hour texting and driving oh
okay 20 miles an hour
correct 2-0 Wow oh it takes my breath
away okay um well there's a lot of
extremes in your story and you're right
you're walking in perfect peace
that passes all understanding and it
does pass understanding that you're
doing that which is wonderful and I'm
glad you're their number one they're not
going to come after you because legally
speaking you're what we call judgment
proof they cannot take disability income
you don't have anything they can get by
being in that status financially you
don't have anything they can get they're
not gonna sue you I suspect they haven't
no nobody has yeah and is the vast
majority of these bills 15 years old or
13 or 14 years old they are all within
the last 13 years but how old are they
the big ones the last major surgery I
have was seven years ago
okay and so out of the five hundred
thousand how much of it is ten years old
or older probably about three hundred
okay and then how much and then the rest
would be between seven and ten correct
okay there's a statute of limitations in
most states on collecting outstanding
debt you've passed that I suspect in
Massachusetts I don't know the law in
every state I'm not an attorney
this happened in Illinois I've only
lived here for you okay well then I
guess Illinois where it would apply all
of the surgeries occurred in Illinois
yeah okay then you'd have to find out
from an Illinois Attorney what the
statute of limitations is but if they
don't collect the debt within a certain
period of time it's uncollectible they
cannot collect it by law I suspect that
they looked at your situation and said
we're not getting this money and on to
the next patient you know and I think
that's what they did which was an act of
mercy albeit apathy type mercy but it
was still mercy and so I suspect you
don't have any debt
I think you might be debt-free because
this is uncollectible debt a due to your
status and B because it has passed the
statute of limitations to where they can
collect it now if someone hands you a
million dollars if I were in your shoes
I would go back even though it's not
legally owed anymore because of the
statute of limitations and I would at
least make some kind of settlement
offers okay because they have taken care
of you right and I would do that but I
in your shoes you're a single mom making
sixteen with repeated brain surgeries
and brain injury I'm not going to put on
you that you have to fight and scratch
and claw through a half-million dollars
on some kind of a moral basis you don't
I would just walk in grace if I were you
if you want to have a little more peace
from a tactical legal standpoint and I
probably would if I were in your shoes I
might say if there is there an attorney
that goes to church with your parents
where you used to go or something like
that that would answer a question for
you as a favor and say you know the
statute of limitations is run on this
they can't collect you don't know any
money and don't worry about it and put
it in a file and put it in the back of
your file drawer for some day when the
next miracle of your life gives your
life you're walking miracle when the
next miracle of your life occurs and you
have two million dollars in your hand if
you want to go back and quote settle up
at that point you can unquote but in
case it's also go on extreme up on all
of my credits yeah you can probably get
it taken off but that doesn't matter
you're not gonna be more on money anyway
oh no I've never had a credit card I
actually got a credit because I needed
to get a car a rental car my job it card
are you kidding
yeah well yeah but you can do that with
your debit card just stay tuned there's
some big stuff coming on this show in
the next few days so but yeah you're
gonna be fine Wow now I think you're
debt-free if you want to do some stuff
to clean off your credit bureau report
you can
because it's passed the statute of
limitations you can if you dispute
something that's on your credit bureau
report and they don't respond or you
have an argument then they are required
by law to take it off so you could go
through item by item and dispute these
but before I did that and stirred them
up I would want to know that it's passed
the statute of limitations that's what
you're looking for the statute of
limitations
hold on I'll have Kelly pick up Kelly
see if contact and see if we can help
her with flexion bully if one of those
guys can help her maybe she's not being
bullied but see if we can Skinner the
information if we can help